however much time you schedule for work
is it's going to fill it so if you say
I'm gonna I have 40 hours for the
project it's gonna take 40 hours yep but
if you say I have four hours for the
project it's going to take four hours
yep I think that that law is more
profound that many people don't know I
mean a lot of people have heard of the
80 20 rule but very few have heard of
Parkinson's law and it's true I mean the
reason I'm able to accomplish a lot each
week is because I say hey this is the
only amount of time I have to do this
right most entrepreneurs they'll be like
oh well you know I've got the whole day
to get it done and so it takes the whole
day whereas I'm like no I've got two
hours to get this done and then I'm
gonna go golf yeah and so I do get it
done in two hours it's good and I still
get to golf right and so I mean most
people like I say when they say they
work 70 hour weeks they're not really
working 70 hours very few are they're
they might be working 30 35. the other
half is spent probably on social media
probably just being inefficient probably
just sitting there with like a dead
stare at the wall not doing anything
like it nobody can focus for 70 80 hours
yeah so Parkinson's law basically stops
that from happening right because you
just give yourself a deadline like we
all do things like on a deadline uh one
example is you know back when you were
in school if you're a good student like
or a decent student anytime you get a
project or a homework whatever it is
like you do it the night before that's
what most people do right right so if
they tell you got a week you're doing it
you know day six but if they tell you
you got a pop quiz tomorrow if you're a
good student you're gonna do it that
night it's been something that we've
always done and it's good like people
operate better when they're backs
against the wall and they they put
pressure on themselves